JP Morgan Chase you've heard of Chase
Bank their CEO Jamie Diamond this is a
guy who Joe Biden often refers to as his
friend and advisor well now he even is
admitting that Florida and Texas they're
doing something right when it comes to
business and that New York ain't looking
so good these days
we've loved Florida we're growing in
Florida left and right you know small
businesses large companies I'm on my way
to Tampa we've got you know major
operations there Orlando major
operations we're opening branches and so
the mayor just joined us at a small
business event we did here we're very
pro pro Florida if you were running the
state you know you should be thinking
how can I make this date off go to well
off for my people so Florida likes
business
they want you to come you know you come
to the floor you see the opt-in Texas is
the same way you know if I was some
other states I mean think about why do
people like going to these dates it's
their taxes is there a pro-business they
want better life for the people it's not
necessary it's on the positive to talk
about so um you know we now have more
employees in Texas than New York State
you know it should have been that way
but Texas loves you to be there and when
you go there they're optimistic they're
optimistic here pro-american optimistic
no unfortunately no
I I don't know that I could have said
that better myself first off the fact
that chase now has more employees in
Texas than in New York is absolutely
wild New York for the last 100 plus
years I mean since the industrial
revolution has been the center of
Finance obviously the United States but
really the entire world and people are
fleeing I mean I'm telling you after
being in New York City for the last
couple days and I was in Midtown I
didn't go all the way downtown to Wall
Street but I was in Midtown which has
tons of high-rises with massive
buildings of people that used to do
business and there were no business
people on the street anymore there are
no people in suits even collar open
shirts they're just not out there it's a
bunch of people in hoodies who all smell
like weed and everyone's up to no good
that's what's happening in New York City
right now and you know he's he's talking
about a diamond obviously from a
financial situation so he's talking
about employment he's talking about
regulations he's talking about taxes but
then it's also about all of the other
stuff that when you move to a place that
allows you to come in and create what
you want to create create
you start being happier you start
actually being friendlier your community
starts being safer because you have
people who kind of know each other and
say hi to each other I'm telling you I
say hi to more people on an average day
walking my dog here then I would say to
hi to in a month in LA because people
would be running the opposite direction
because of covet and masks and dogs
can't sniff each other and all the
craziness so there is a culture
there is a culture of freedom and
success that is happening right here
[Music]